>>> YOU'RE WEARING YOUR NEW
SHIRT!
>> YEAH.
DOES IT LOOK OKAY?
>> YOU LOOK GREAT, SWEETIE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
BECAUSE I'M REALLY NERVOUS TO
MEET YOUR PARENTS, YOU KNOW?
I DON'T WANT TO LOOK STUPID.
>> OH, THEY'RE GOING TO LOVE
YOU.
>> OKAY.
ALL RIGHT, I JUST REALLY WANT TO
IMPRESS THEM.
[ DOORBELL RINGING ]
♪♪♪
>> HEY!
>> HEY, SWEETIE!
>> HI, MOM.
>> COME HERE.
>> HI.
MOM, DAD, THIS IS MICHAEL.
THAT'S WEIRD.
HE WAS HERE JUST A SECOND AGO.
>> WELL, WE CAN'T WAIT TO MEET
HIM.
>> MICHAEL!
HONEY?
>> I BET YOU CAN'T FIND ME.
>> WHAT?
WAS THAT HIM?
>> WHAT DID HE SAY?
>> TRY AND FIND ME!
HEE-HEE-HEE.
>> MICHAEL, STOP IT!
OKAY, COME OUT HERE AND MEET MY
PARENTS.
>> HEE-HEE-HEE, WHERE AM I?
>> HONEY, WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> I THINK HE'S JUST NERVOUS.
HE REALLY WANTS TO IMPRESS YOU.
>> WHY WOULD THAT IMPRESS US?
>> DOES HE HIDE A LOT?
>> NO, HE'S NEVER DONE THIS
BEFORE.
>> I BET YOU CAN'T FIND ME!
>> OH, I BET I CAN!
♪♪♪
>> DAD, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
>> I'M GOING TO FIND THIS GUY.
>> YOU'RE VERY COLD.
>> MAKE IT FAIR, GIVE US A CLUE.
>> DON'T YOU WANT TO SEE WHAT I
LOOK LIKE?
HEE-HEE-HEE.
>> THAT WAS A BIG YES!
I GOT TO FIND THIS GUY IF I WANT
TO SEE WHAT HE LOOKS LIKE.
>> FOLLOW THE LITTLE GAY ELF.
HEE-HEE-HEE!
COME AND FIND ME!
>> HE'S IN THE CLOSET!
WHERE IS THIS TURD?
>> DAD!
>> HA HA, YOU'RE GETTING WARMER.
>> OH, HE'S UNDER THE BED!
I GOT YOU NOW!
DAMN IT.
>> NOT THERE.
HEE-HEE-HEE.
>> COMING FROM THE WALLS.
>> HE'S NOT IN THE WALLS!
DAD, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
>> I'M TRYING TO FIND THE DAMN
GUY!
GOTCHA!
>> I GUESS YOU DON'T WANT TO SEE
WHAT I LOOK LIKE!
>> YOU KNOW I DO!
>> THEN FOLLOW MY VOICE.
HEE-HEE-HEE-HEE.
>> OH, I GOT YOU NOW.
FOOLED AGAIN!
>> SOUND LIKE SOMEONE'S GOT PIE
IN THE FACE.
>> NO, THEY DON'T.
>> HONEY, THIS IS INSANE.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT, THIS IS TOO
HARD.
GIVE US ANOTHER CLUE.
>> HEE-HEE-HEE, YOU SEE, I MIGHT
BE WHERE YOU WATCH TV.
>> IN THE TV!
>> OH, CRAP, I GAVE IT AWAY!
♪♪♪
>> I GOT HIM!
>> HELP ME!
HELP!
I'M STUCK!
WHAT TOOK YOU SO LONG?
HELP ME, I'M STUCK!
>> MICHAEL, WHERE ARE YOUR
CLOTHES?
>> I COULDN'T FIT BACK HERE WITH
THAT NEW SHIRT ON!
>> DID YOU GREASE YOUR BODY?
>> JUST MY FACE AND MY CHEST.
I COULDN'T FIT BACK THERE.
THIS WHOLE PLAN IS NOT WORKING
AT ALL.
>> WHAT WAS YOUR PLAN?
>> TO LOOK COOL IN FRONT OF YOUR
PARENTS.
LOOK AT WHAT LOVE MADE ME DO,
BABE.
PLEASE TO MEET YOU, MR. CHARLES.
MRS. CHARLES.
I HOPE MY HIDING THING WASN'T
TOO STUPID.
AND I'M SORRY IF I RUINED YOUR
CLOTHES WITH MY PIE TRAP.
>> YOU DIDN'T.
>> CRAP.
LOOK, YOU JUST TOLD ME HOW GREAT
THEY WERE AND I JUST REALLY
WANTED TO IMPRESS THEM.
I DIDN'T WANT TO BE A LOSER.
I DIDN'T WANT TO BE "THAT GUY."
>> "THAT GUY."
I LOVE THAT.
I SAY THAT TOO.
I LIKE YOU FOR MY DAUGHTER.
A LOT.
>> I DO TOO, SIR.
YES, THANK YOU, SIR.
VERY GOOD, SIR.
>> LET ME SEE HOW HANDSOME YOU
ARE.
THAT'S VERY NICE.
GOOD.
THERE.
VERY HANDSOME.
VERY GOOD.
HE LOOKS GOOD.
VERY, VERY GOOD.
VERY HANDSOME.
VERY NICE.
HE LOOKS GOOD.
I LIKE THAT.
VERY, VERY GOOD.
VERY HANDSOME.
THAT'S VERY NICE.
>> MERRY CHRISTMAS, EVERYONE.